hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe
I'm your host Sean Carroll today's big
idea I'm pretty sure it's gonna be one
of your favorites it's definitely one of
my favorites the idea is gravity by
which we mean of course general
relativity Einstein's theory of gravity
we already mentioned gravity in the
context of Newtonian theory now we're
gonna move on to the real stuff and let
me be clear about one of the reasons why
this is gonna be one of your favorites
not only is general relativity by itself
just a wonderful theory you know I had a
I wrote a textbook on general relativity
space time and geometry which I opened
by saying general relativity is the most
beautiful physical theory ever invented
I think that's absolutely true I'll try
to make the case for that as much as I
love quantum mechanics general
relativity is prettier but the other
thing is it's also easier we've been
doing a bit of quantum mechanics quantum
field theory stuff and I understand that
a lot of it is abstract and very far
removed more everyday lives and very
difficult to get it's worth it and I
hope that some of the nuances have come
across but it can be taxing and I
completely understand that whereas
general relativity even though it has
its own mathematical language and in
some ways it is also a little bit
removed from our everyday lives it is
easier to understand sorry I'm
hesitating because there's Ariel as
complaining in the background so I'm not
playing fetch with her sorry about that
you gotta put up with that this is an
irony of course because general
relativity has a reputation for being
incredibly difficult to understand the
old joke is that Arthur Eddington the
British astrophysicist who was a great
popularizer of relativity as soon as it
came out he was asked at a talk you know
I've been told the questioner says
there's only 12 people there's only
three people in the world who understand
general relativity can you tell me who
the third one is after him and Einstein
and Eddington hesitated and the
questioner says oh don't be so modest
and anything says oh no I'm trying to
think of who the third person is this is
not true was never the case that only
two or three people understood general
relativity it's it's a language of
mathematics that we need to understand
but we can get there we can get there
faster than most people because you've
listened to the previous video that
we've had about geometry and
apology so you know something about the
geometry of curved space and curved
space-time already so for us it's gonna
be a breeze all right let's go so let's
think about Newtonian gravity first
we've already talked about Newtonian
gravity professor Newton told us that
the force due to gravity
looks like Newton's constant G times one
mass m1 times the other mass m2 over R
squared the inverse square law of
gravity so you have two objects there is
action at a distance in between them
they pull each other together
proportional to their masses and
inversely proportional to the distance
between them and then Laplace says that
you can think of this as the slope the
force due to gravity can be thought of
that as the slope of the gravitational
potential field so you have some field
Phi as a function of distance R and it
looks like this since you're sitting
here and the slope of that field gives
you the force of gravity it's not a
different theory than Newton's it's
exactly the same as Newtonian gravity
but it's put into the language of a
field theory so that rather than simply
action at a distance you have an
equation that tells you how the field
changes from point to point that is a
purely local equation so that's a step
forward however this is you know this is
1600s this is around 1800 but then
Maxwell comes along with
electromagnetism ok Maxwell and other
people but one of the great achievements
of Maxwell's electromagnetism in the
mid-1800s
was understanding that there's a
unification of electric phenomena
magnetic phenomena and also light and
radiation and part of understanding the
symmetries of that theory was Einstein's
appreciation that the speed of light
would be the same to every one that you
did not need an ether pervading
space-time to explain any of it and the
pole theory that we now call special
relativity and the reason I'm bringing
these up is of course because Newtonian
gravity is not compatible with special
relativity so Newton's equation here for
the force due to an object with a mass
I'm acting on an object with mass m2 m1
and m2 there's no time in here the time
parameter the time of the universe does
not appear in this equation which means
that if I move one object very very
quickly the gravitational force on the
other one changes instantaneously no
matter how far away it is there's no
speed of light built into this equation
anywhere and when Maxwell came up with
enm electricity and magnetism and then
Einstein codified it in terms of special
relativity the speed of light has this
really important feature you cannot send
signals faster than the speed of light
if Newtonian gravity were true you would
be able to send signals faster than the
speed of light through the force of
gravity in some object that you're
waving back and forth so Einstein knew
this he knew that you would have to
modify a Newtonian gravity and I think
that even before Einstein probably
people appreciated it they appreciated
that the symmetries of Newtonian
mechanics were different than the
symmetries of Maxwell's electromagnetism
there's a Galilean invariance in
Newtonian mechanics and there is Lorenz
Ian's invariance in relativity those two
things are not the same thing
so I thought a lot about how to do this
and there's sort of a general way that
you would try to think about how to do
this which is to write down a
relativistic field theory in other words
to update Laplace's theory in such a way
it would give you all the features the
gravity had people tried that it didn't
really work nordstrom among other people
was it was a person who tried it but it
didn't really work for various reasons
we're not going to go down all those
blind paths we're gonna skip right to
the right answer so Einstein comes along
after inventing special relativity you
remember just to put this in perspective
Einstein didn't really invent special
relativity he perfected it circa 1905 he
really was the one who understood what
special relativity really meant and
explained it got rid of the ether all
that stuff we now know as Lorentz
invariance was understood at a deeper
level and in that same year 1905
Einstein suggested that light could be
thought of as particles which we now
call photons and he did other things as
well so he was thinking very much about
quantum mechanical phenomena this whole
time and also thermodynamics and
statistical mechanics
but certainly after putting relativity
together special relativity in 1905
gravity was foremost on his mind and he
spent around ten years 1905 to 1915
under Supes understanding how you could
fit gravity into the relativistic
framework before coming up with general
relativity and the names aren't very
good special relativity general
relativity it's not really special
versus general it's two very different
things special relativity like quantum
mechanics or classical mechanics is a
framework it's a sub framework of
classical mechanics everything here is
classical even though it's relativity
we're not doing quantum classical means
non Quantum's we're classical for this
whole video so relative special
relativity is a different version of
classical mechanics than Newtonian
space-time is but it's still classical
mechanics okay general relativity is a
specific theory so once you have special
relativity that's a framework in which
you can build many theories like
Maxwell's electromagnetism like
relativistic quantum field theory the
standard model of particle physics is a
theory that lives within the framework
of special relativity it's a quantum
version but still the same basic
framework there general relativity is
also a different theory that lives
within that framework that special
relativity sets up so it's actually in
some sense more specific than special
relativity it's the theory of special
relativity when you let space-time be
curved and you give it a specific way of
being curved and you call that gravity
so his breakthrough Einstein's
breakthrough came from as it often did
Brian Stein thought experiments you know
he was a genius clearly he's Einstein
but he wasn't the most mathematically
inclined physicist around even at that
time he was the genius at thinking of
things physically and in terms of
thought experiments that gave you
immense physical insight into what's
going on
so the thought experiment that he came
up with is the following take a box a
sealed box that you can't get out of but
a physicist inside this box okay and
they're doing experiments and you're
giving him the task find out what are
the conditions in which the box is
embedded the bigger outside world okay
so you could ask for example is there an
electric
field here's an electric field vector
imagine there's some electric field
pointing vertically both inside and
outside the box could you do experiments
inside the box that lets you know that
there's an electric field surrounding
you in all places and the answer is
clearly yes and so Einstein wouldn't put
it in these terms but what we can do is
say look imagine there's an electron
II - and there's a proton P + okay two
different particles with two different
electric charges the way that the sign
convention works out the proton gets
accelerated in the direction of the
electric field so the proton gets
accelerated vertically upward the
electron will get accelerated vertically
downward so something different happens
to the electron and the proton because
they have different electric charges in
the presence of an electric field
therefore if there were zero electric
field they would just sit there if there
is an electric field pointing in some
direction they begin to cell accelerate
in opposite senses along that direction
in which the electric field is pointing
so the answer to the question can you
detect an electric field while you're in
a sealed box is clearly yes so Einstein
says okay let's play the same game for
gravity okay imagine there's some
gravitational attraction G pointing
downward and here's your physicist okay
can they do an experiment to detect the
gravitational field and know they're in
a sealed box they can't just look
outside go yes I'm sitting on the earth
okay therefore I know there's a
gravitational field they're not allowed
to look outside well you can say you
know let me take a heavy object and a
light object all right two things with
different masses and therefore in some
sense different couplings to the
gravitational field and you can drop
them but ever since Galileo we've known
that a heavy object a light object will
fall the same acceleration in a
gravitational field as long as the air
resistance is negligible and so on right
so Einstein says you know okay I can
drop two objects but they're unlike
electricity and magnetism the objects in
the gravitational field will always fall
in exactly the same way and you might
you might say well still they're falling
therefore I've detected the
gravitational field if I have an object
right here and I drop it I have detected
the gravitation
field right but Einstein who is smarter
than me or you says you don't know that
what if there's not a gravitational
field and what if I draw my box better
but instead of that you're in a rocket
ship okay here's the engine of your
rocket ship and so you're accelerating
upwards the same thing would happen
right you're accelerating upwards you
take these two objects you let them fall
and they followed exactly the same rate
in fact they're not really falling at
all they're remaining stationary and
your box is accelerating up into them
and so what Einstein says is maybe this
Galilean result the two different
objects will accelerate at the same rate
in a gravitational field extends more
broadly maybe it's not just the physics
of falling objects maybe it's all of
physics he says maybe there is no
experiment you can do in that box which
could actually tell the difference
between being in an accelerated box
versus that being stationary on the
earth for some other gravitational field
okay so we're comparing stationery on
earth and our usual way of thinking
about it - accelerating at 1g one earth
gravitational acceleration but out in
outer space far away from the actual
earth and we're also imagining you can't
hear the rocket engine roaring or
anything like that okay in that case
Einstein goes on to invent what he calls
the principle of equivalence and in case
you're wondering the equivalence here is
between gravitation and acceleration he
says in a small region of space-time and
this is important okay in a small region
of space-time sometimes you can forget
that part
they shouldn't no experiment can
distinguish
I can do better than that I always try
to rush because I write very slowly and
then I become sloppy and it slows me
down there's some life lesson here to be
learned no experiment can distinguish
between gravity and uniform acceleration
so obviously if your rocket ship is
boosting and then stopping and boosting
again you would know that it's a rocket
ship the earth doesn't do that to you
but uniform acceleration is just like
gravity I knew that was gonna happen
there we go okay I can't put a period on
the sentence good it's too close to the
edge all right so that's the principle
of equivalence Einstein says there's
something special about gravity
something that is different between
gravity and other forces of nature the
only one he knew very well was
electromagnetism but still this is a
special thing you can tell whether there
is an electric field around you you
can't tell whether it's a gravitational
field if you're in a small region of
space-time now well the reason why I'm
emphasizing the small region of
space-time bit is that people wise guys
keep coming up with proposed counter
examples to the principle of equivalence
and usually it's because they're
ignoring the fact that there's the
phrase in the small region of space-time
so in a large region of space-time so
let's imagine this is the earth and
let's imagine that your physicist box
was bigger than the earth here's your
box that you're stuck in okay so there's
an obvious experiment you can do to tell
the earth is beneath you you can drop a
ball here and a ball here on far distant
parts of your box and they will move
towards the center of the earth in other
words it will move ever so slightly
toward each other whereas in an
accelerated box they'll move exactly
parallel and the same thing is true here
if you're truly on the earth literally
here in your in your room wherever
you're watching this you could drop two
things and in principle they do not move
on parallel lines they move closer to
each other as time goes on because the
earth is the center of the earth is a
point toward which they're attracted but
that's that effect that difference goes
away in the limit as you're looking at
smaller and smaller regions so already
this phrase in this
region of space-time it has a bit of a
flavor of calculus to it doesn't it
remember remember when we defined
derivatives so we did derivatives in
calculus we had some function of X as a
function of X and we said look there was
a curve there and what you want is the
derivative of F at that point okay and
what you do is you zoom in on it and
then you draw a straight line and what
you say is that as you come closer and
close your ease to get to smaller and
smaller parts of the curve that you're
interested in you can approximate that
curve no matter how curved you was
originally as you go to the limit is
that you're looking at smaller and
smaller regions it looks more and more
like a straight line so the principle of
equivalence is saying something similar
about space-time and in fact so you can
translate the principle of equivalence
pov restated or implies let's put it
that way it's not exactly the same
statement but the implication that
einstein drew from it is that physics in
small enough regions I won't keep
writing the whole thing of space-time
reduces to special relativity so what
he's saying here is the rules of special
relativity by hypothesis we just don't
put gravity in there okay special
relativity is not a theory of gravity
but what he's gonna say is when we do
include gravity we don't give up on
special relativity entirely we say that
special relativity applies in the limit
as you go to smaller and smaller regions
of space-time and just like calculus
comes about by saying in a small region
when you zoom in on a curve it looks
like a straight line you can go from
this statement that physics looks like
special relativity in a tiny region to a
statement that resembles differential
geometry okay differential geometry is
secretly what we were doing when we did
geometry in previous video this is the
point of what Gauss and Riemann did
because rather than taking a uniform
smooth geometry everywhere like you
would have over a sphere they said well
we can look at individual points in some
wildly fluctuating geometry and describe
characterize the curvature of the
manifold locally at each point so this
is the word where this is where the word
differential comes in differential just
a fancy way of saying derivative this is
calculus applied to geometry so the
point of differential geometry in some
sense is in small regions geometry looks
Euclidean so we didn't I could have set
this in the geometry video but didn't
say it out loud but this is the point so
if you have let's say a sphere okay
here's a sphere one way of thinking
about what Gauss and Riemann did one way
of thinking about how they managed to
make sense of the geometry of different
curvatures in different places was they
said look if I take one point on the
sphere and I zoom in on it just like the
whole surface of the earth is roughly
spherical but if I mean one tiny patch
of it it looks flat right that's why
there are people who think the whole
thing is flat because they don't
understand differential geometry they
don't understand that the small region
can look flat even though the whole
region is actually quite curved and what
Gauss and Riemann do is that they
actually use their brains to invent a
whole mathematical structure here and
they're able to sort of say in the
vicinity of that one point all geometry
looks exactly Euclidean in the limit as
you in a curved manifold to go to
smaller and smaller regions you look
more and more like there's no curvature
at all and then you can build up how to
glue together the small regions to
describe the curvature globally so it's
clear it should be clear it's clear to
you could be you know as a leading
discussion but you go from the principle
of equivalence which is this thought
experiment okay that's very very
physical very intuitive very
visualizable and then you get this
implication physics in small regions
reduces to special relativity which
sounds exactly like the beginning of
differential geometry Einstein had no
idea help this he did this was not you
know some clever store
he told after the fact he got the
principle of equivalence but he didn't
know exactly what it meant he was
bouncing around so between 1905 when he
was stolen to clerk 1915 he was already
pretty famous in between he was bouncing
around he got his PhD from Zurich and
then he went to Baron anyway I think to
Prague and then he went back to Zurich
and when he was it back in Zurich he's
still thinking about this stuff and so
but he ranted all his old friends and
Zurich because he's got a PhD there one
of his friends was Marcel Grossman who
was a mathematician and Einstein
described to Grossman what he's thinking
about and Grossman says yeah well you
need some Riemannian geometry and
Einstein says well what is that I agree
so Grossman taught Einstein rimoni in
geometry and it's after some initial
reluctance Einstein eventually says this
is exactly what I need right so Einstein
eventually says gravity the thing that I
can get rid of in a small region of
space-time is just the curvature of
space-time took them a while to actually
figure out the equations associated with
this motto but this is the idea if in a
small region of a manifold you can make
the geometry look Euclidian that's
equivalent to saying in a small region
of space-time the geometry looks like
flat space-time of special relativity
and then the curvature shows up as you
go to larger and larger regions and
Einstein says that must be what gravity
is because that's in this picture right
here you see that the gravity is
detectable when you can go to larger and
larger regions of space-time and a small
region disappears in larger regions it's
very very important yet another way of
saying the same thing is Einstein is
saying if there is a difference between
gravity and the other forces of nature
okay in Newtonian physics what you would
have said is that gravity is a force
that lives on top of space-time and it
has there's an equation for what the
force is there it is inverse square law
okay in some sense according to Einstein
the problem the reason why gravity had
been difficult to fit into special
relativity is because gravity is not a
force
a force you could detect by doing some
experiment if the force is real you
should be able to detect it but gravity
you can't not in a small region of
space-time if you're locked in that
little box so Einstein says instead of
thinking of gravity as a force what you
should do is think of it as a feature of
space-time itself that's why you can't
detect it because everything is in
space-time everything is affected by the
curvature of space-time in exactly the
same way it's not an external force that
some things can feel and some things
don't
it's a feature of space-time itself so
that's a very very good perspective and
so you know if I'm hesitating because
look if you were me right after you
first learned general relativity you
would have been one of those people who
went around making fun of other people
who thought of gravity is a force
because you have said no no no you're
very old-fashioned gravity is not a
force gravity is the curvature of
space-time and you know now that I'm a
little bit more mature than that I know
that really the answer is who cares it
doesn't matter whether you want to call
gravity a force or not if Newton had
been right you know if all of Newtonian
mechanics had been right the idea of a
force was absolutely central F equals MA
right it's really an important part of
how we defined the theory but he wasn't
we've moved on beyond that now in
quantum field theory once we get there
we're not doing quantum field theory
today but in quantum field theory you
don't talk about forces at all there's
no F equals MA in quantum field theory
there's just a bunch of different fields
interacting with each other so we still
use the word force because it is
sometimes convenient ok it is not an
essential part of the ontology of nature
it's a sometimes convenient concept and
that's just as true in general
relativity as anywhere else if someone
wants to say the pen falls because the
force of gravity is pulling it fine let
them do that
don't be it don't be a stickler about
whether or not gravity is a force but
you should appreciate that gravity
really is the curvature of space-time
because there is one shift of attitude
that actually does make difference make
make a big difference let's let's put it
this way
think of a table here's a table
okay again drawing is not supposed to be
the strong suit here and I'm gonna draw
a coffee mug on the table maybe we're at
apologists drinking our mug of coffee
and not sure whether it's a coffee cup
or a donut okay and the coffee cup is
just sitting there on the table right
and you can ask yourself is the coffee
cup accelerating and this is something
that Newton and Einstein would have
given genuinely different answers to
because Newton says no what do you mean
of course the coffee cup is not
accelerating it's on the table the
tables on the floor presumably nothing
is moving acceleration is the rate of
change of velocity the velocity is zero
and it stays zero the velocity is not
changing therefore it's not accelerating
Einstein would say yes it is
accelerating because I'm stein says that
the natural state of motion of objects
in space-time is free fall that is to
say not being pushed by not just a
rocketship engine but also by a table
under view or if you're sitting down
right now by the chair underneath you or
if you're standing that the floor
underneath your feet okay he says look
if you're just standing up of course
you're being accelerated even if you're
not running or walking if you're
standing still you can feel the
acceleration in your feet right that's
why you feel heavy if you're sitting
down you can feel the acceleration in
your butt pushing you upward the natural
thing so Newton would say if I move the
table away the coffee cup would start
accelerate and falling but it's not
accelerating when it's just sitting
there
Einstein would say it is being
accelerated by the table it's being
pushed away from its natural state of
motion and if you quickly remove the
table the coffee cup would undergo its
natural free fall motion so just like
inertial trajectories are special in
special relativity unaccelerated
trajectories are special they're just as
special in general relativity they seem
curved to us you know the earth goes
around the Sun that does not seem like a
straight line like an like an
unaccelerated trajectory would be but
what Einstein says is
that these trajectories are geodesics
which is a fancy way of saying extremal
distance paths we talked about this in
we talked about geometry one way of
defining the generalization of a
straight line is to say you have two
points you connect them with a whole
bunch of different conceptual paths the
shortest one is the straight line right
in flat space if you're in curved space
or curved space-time there might not be
a straight line in the conventional
sense but there's still an extremal
distance path I would like to be able to
say a shortest distance path but
actually works out to be a longest time
path in relativity so I'm gonna say
extremal distance okay but this is the
generalization of a straight line and
this is what objects want to do in
curved space-time objects want to move
on the closest thing they can to a
straight line so the motion of the earth
around the Sun in space-time is the best
it can do to move on a straight line it
doesn't seem to be straight to us
because there are no exactly straight
lines because space-time itself is
curved that's the lesson of general
relativity so you are accelerating right
now unless you just jumped off a
building or something like that good so
that that that concludes the truly fun
part of our of our video well it depends
what do you mean by fun okay this is the
conceptual part you got it now you
understand the conceptual beginnings of
general relativity of course there's
more work to be done because we need to
mathematize it we need to turn into a
real rigorous theory of nature how are
we gonna do that okay well you need to
talk about what is the amount of
curvature you have if gravity is the
curvature of space-time where to go
gravity is the curvature of space-time
geodesics are extremely distance paths
you need to attach some equations to
that and we know how to do that because
we talked about curvature before in the
video about geometry so curvature the
way that we talked about it was in terms
of parallel transport remember quantum
chromodynamics okay remember when we did
the gauge theory video we talked about
quarks and how they could be thought of
as living in this three dimensional
space
color red green blue and you might want
a parallel transport a certain quark
field to some other part of space-time
where red green and blue might be
oriented differently and you would have
a connection field that tells you how to
do that and then you quantize the
connection field the connexion field is
all over space-time and the quantum
fluctuations in the connection field
give rise in this case to gluons or to
photons if we were doing QED etc and
then there this the connection tells you
how to do parallel transport and then
curvature is the failure of parallel
transport around a closed loop to bring
you back to where you started so we mean
here is that if we take a vector and we
parallel transport it around a little
tiny loop through space-time if the
space-time in whatever thing we were
moving like the cork fields or in color
space if you parallel transport them
around a loop if there's no curvature to
the gauge field no curvature to the
gluon field connection then the quarks
come back exactly to where they start
okay but if there is curvature to that
connection field then they might be
rotated a little bit and this is what
curvature measures and the curvature for
space-time is special and this is the
beginning of why general relativity is a
little bit different than all those
other gauge theories general relativity
is absolutely a gauge theory in some
very well-defined sense it is also
indubitably different than the other
gauge theories and the reason why is
because when we move around a quark the
little vector that is the quark is
pointing in a fictitious internal color
space it's not pointing up or pointing
left or pointing forward okay it's
pointing in red green blue space which
is a fake space which we make up to
mathematically describe what's going on
whereas in space-time you have a
trajectory and the geodesic trajectory
is one that parallel transports its own
velocity vector or momentum vector which
ever way you want to put it okay so
parallel transport so let's put this way
geodesic okay straight-line equivalent
equals you parallel transport your own
momentum or your own velocity that's
saying that's why it's special because
your velocity or your momentum is a
vector that has a direction in
space-time okay it's not in some
fictitious color space it's pointing up
or down or in some linear combination or
something like that okay so that's why
space-time is a little bit different
geometrically and that's good news and
bad news all right and so we don't need
to keep thinking about the geometry of
gauge theories cuz we're interested in
space-time right now but I want to let
you know that there is that difference
there so in space-time
just like in gauge theories II have this
notion of parallel transport but there's
also an alternative you also have a
notion of distance between points okay
that is related to the way you have a
parallel transporting etc this is what
is different in general relativity than
in other gauge theories so alternatively
this is a one definition of geodesic
okay alternatively geodesic equals as we
just wrote extremal distance path so
what that means is we have again let's
say this is a geodesic connecting two
points this to you desk has a length let
me move it over here a little bit and
the length L well what is it I don't
know what it is you could go and
actually measure what it is but one way
of figuring it out would be to divide it
up into little segments remember
differential geometry we go into tiny
little regions and then we call this
little tiny part you give it a length DL
I'm gonna write that as a curved L
because otherwise just looks like the
number one okay so D lowercase squared
- L is the distance along that little
tiny bit of the interval and then the
whole length along the path L is the sum
of all of the little infant asthma
length DL okay that's easy now if that
part was easy the question is what is do
how do we know like given some actual
path what do you mean by being given
some actual path you might be given
coordinates okay like there's some
coordinates on the sphere on the earth
or in space whatever if you're NASA you
need to have a coordinate system that
extends throughout the solar system
heliocentric coordinates if you Center
them on the Sun for example geocentric
have you centered them on the earth and
then you might want to specify your path
you want to tell your path to somebody
else you need to say here are the
coordinates of my path as I travel along
it okay so the relationship between
coordinates and the path is very
important so we want is a formula for
the infinitesimal distance in terms of
the coordinates and the coordinates once
you're in curved space-time you can't
just say well choose right angles
coordinates choose Cartesian coordinates
okay because there aren't any like on a
sphere you can't do that on some wildly
curved space-time you can't do that so
you need a way to do this no matter what
the coordinates are doing you need a
perfectly general way of seeing what is
this little infinitesimal length so what
we can do is basically we alluded to
this and we talked about geometry we can
generalize Pythagoras's theorem all
right so let's imagine that here your
coordinates and I'm drawing them in some
curvilinear way because there's no
preferred structure right angles
parallelism anything like that is an
arbitrary coordinate system call one of
them X the other one Y what we want to
do is figure out what is the distance
between two points okay and so this is a
small bit of X DX this is a small bit of
Y dy from here to here this is DX there
to there and this is DL there there so
it looks like it should kind of be
Pythagoras's theorem right DL squared is
DX squared plus dy squared but these are
not right angles and there might be
other things going on so you need to be
able to generalize
Pythagoras's theorem and the general
formula that you would write down looks
like this and it's gonna be a little
weird looking I'll explain why so again
the Pythagoras would be Pythagoras is
not right in this case but it would be
DL squared is DX squared plus dy squared
so we want more general and what we'll
do is we'll keep the feature that DL
squared
scales as DX squared or dy squared okay
so if the distances change you got to
square everything so the more general
formula is DL squared is some
coefficient a times DX squared plus some
coefficient B times DX times dy and this
is why it's going to look weird I'm
gonna write B again but then dy times DX
plus a third coefficient C times dy
squared okay now this is a
generalization it's quadratic it either
you know there's either two appearances
of DX or two appearances of dy or one H
of DX and dy so that makes sense
good the part that doesn't make sense is
why did I have DX dy and then again dy
DX why didn't I just right since DX dy
equals dy DX why did I just write two
times B times DX dy well the answer is
because this way of writing it leads to
a very efficient compact way of
expressing this in more general
circumstances I invent what is called
the metric tensor okay we have used the
word tensor once before when we talked
about the Riemann curvature tensor it
was a way of compactly summarizing a
whole bunch of different numbers so it's
not a single number it's not a single
vector it can be a matrix or an embedded
set of matrices or something complicated
like that the metric tensor is actually
a pretty simple one the metric tensor g
IJ which is that those indices I and J
remind us that X
I are the coordinates either X or Y so
that's X 1 and X 2 this is not X to the
first power x squared this is the first
X which is X the second X which is y in
this case if you imagine you had a third
dimension X 3 would be Z etc and gij are
the different values of G in these
different directions so G X X is the
thing that multiplies DX squared so it's
a but let me let me before I get there
let me just write G X X and then there's
g x y gy x and g YY and in this case
that is a and then be multiplying DX dy
be again multiplying dy DX and c
multiplying dy dy ok so that's why I
wrote this equation in this weird form
where I repeated this thing twice
because I can write it as a square
matrix which is symmetric G XY always
equals G Y X but this just turns out to
be a convenient way of representing
those two numbers all right so you see
it's getting a little abstract but
hopefully not too much I think this is
one of those things where just a little
bit of work thinking about the notation
is going to pay off I promise you I
think I promise you I promise that I
hope that it pays off how about that so
the reason why this is useful because we
have this formula for a tiny little
distance and we can write it as d l
squared equals a sum over both I and J
of G IJ d X I DX j that is the compact
way of writing g XX DX squared plus g x
y DX dy plus g y x dy DX plus g y y dy
squared it's a little bit simpler right
in fact this becomes so simple i really
shouldn't do this but it becomes so
simple just so you get to know what you
see elsewhere that people start stop
writing the summation sign I think it
was Einstein who gets credit for saying
as long as I write g IJ
a DXi dij dxj you know I'm gonna be
summing over inj so I'm gonna write the
summation sign anymore
okay the Einstein summation convention
it's called good so this is the data
that we need to describe a curved
manifold if I want to be able to
calculate the length by the way you know
I didn't because I forgot to say this
out loud the point is these two
definitions of oops
these two definitions of geodesics are
the same in general tivity you can
either say i extremize the lengths along
a curve or i parallel transport my own
velocity vector they get me the same
curves they get me the same geodesics so
it doesn't matter which I use but
distances are useful for other reasons
so distance is sort of the the metric
that tells you how distances are
calculated is the thing that is the
primary focus of what your attention is
and general relativity everything comes
from that so this is the metric metric
tensor something like that but this is
the metric on some two-dimensional
imaginary space let's just go right to
space-time what we care about right
here's space-time we're gonna now have
four coordinates so we're gonna start
using Greek letters X mu there's an old
joke that math becomes difficult when
the symbols start being in the Greek
alphabet rather than the Roman alphabet
it's of course completely irrelevant
what alphabet you use but it is somehow
true that once you start running out of
letters in the Roman alphabet and have
to start using Greek letters things
might be becoming more difficult the
space-time indices coordinates are T for
time XY and Z and I am setting the speed
of light equal to one otherwise it would
make no sense to combine time with space
right relativity is where the speed of
light comes in and we're certainly doing
relativity and conventionally what we do
is we label these X 0 X 1 X 2 and X 3 so
time is the zeroth coordinate of
space-time and why do we call it zero
we're either sticking at the end and
calling it the fourth well you know
sometimes we might want to talk about
more than
or dimensions or fewer than four
dimensions different numbers of
dimensions time is always singled out so
it's more convenient to call it X zero
and if we get another dimension of space
we would call that X 4 etc okay and then
there is a metric so how about just for
flat space-time for flat space-time
that's what we study that's what we
talked about in the video on space-time
and we can summarize all of what we said
in that video by one formula for the
metric for flat space-time which is
minus 1 0 0 0 0 plus 1 0 0 0 0 plus 1 0
0 0 0 plus 1 tada notice by the way I'm
just gonna write this and I'm gonna
erase it flat Euclidean space also has a
metric just two dimensional tabletop
right gij
equals plus 1 0 0 plus 1 that's it
that's all flat including geometry
summarized in one little formula also
from that you derive everything clearly
something a little bit trickier is going
on oops in space-time because there's a
minus sign there what is that all about
well that's reflecting the fact that
video it's nice to see it pay off right
it's nice to see our previous work in
previous videos come come to fruition
here we mentioned that there is a
difference between how we calculate
lengths in space and time there's a
relative minus sign which means that
that's why if you have a path through
space the analog of a straight line is
the shortest distance path through space
if you're in space-time the analog is
the longest time path that's because of
the minus sign here in the metric and
what this means is that the interval in
space-time so not the physical distance
but the interval in spacetime is minus
DT squared plus DX squared plus dy
Plus DZ squared and that should be
familiar to us because when we did our
space-time diagrams X T we drew light
cones like this and x equals plus or
minus T that's the light cone coming out
of this point okay at 45-degree angles
because C equals one they have the
feature that D s equals zero
no time nor no spatial distance is
elapsed as measured by someone moving at
the speed of light and that's because
minus one and plus one cancel each other
out in the metric all right that was
just a rehash of what we've already done
in the space-time video so now let's let
things be curved okay so in curved
space-time remember professors Gauss and
Riemann told us that in curved
space-time or curved space they didn't
think about space-time but it's actually
kind of an easy generalization but gousa
riemann said if you go to small regions
of space things look Euclidean Einstein
says in small regions of space-time
things look special relativity Anor
Minkowski and if you want so this is
Minkowski this is the Minkowski metric
Minkowski or minkovski was Einstein's
professor and again you know Einsteins
slightly resistant to being too mathy so
it was a Minkowski who after special
relativity came along said you really
should think about this in terms of four
dimensional geometry and Einstein was
like no don't don't make me do that but
eventually he gave in so is Minkowski
who actually wrote down this metric for
the first time so curved space-time in
small regions you can make the metric
look Minkowski that's supposed to be an
arrow sorry so what does that mean
so at one point in curved space-time G
mu nu at that particular point let's say
X star equals minus one plus one plus
one plus one and zeros elsewhere but
elsewhere it changes elsewhere it's
different
so in general Jeanie nu is always
symmetric so you know this element is
always gonna be the same as that element
whatever it is they're gonna be equal
just like it was up here B equals B okay
but in general the metric in an
arbitrary curved space-time is not going
to be minus one plus one plus one plus
one it's gonna be some functions some
function of T XY and Z in general all
these different 4x4 matrix elements are
going to be different functions of
space-time okay so I can choose
coordinates in which the metric looks
like flat Minkowski space at one point
that is the mathematical translation of
the principle of equivalence the
principle of equivalence says I can make
gravity disappear in small regions of
space differential geometry says I can
make the curved space-time metric look
Minkowski in in a small region of
space-time that is the mathematician of
the principle of equivalence so if it
deviates elsewhere all the information
about the curvature of space-time is in
that deviation is contained in how the
components these different entries in
the matrix for the metric have the
metric components change with space and
time so for example let's do a simple
example of a curved space-time
the simplest example there is is
actually kind of important one the
expanding universe we know that
cosmologically the universe looks pretty
much the same on large scales in space
but it's expanding in time what does
that mean in terms of a metric well it
means you can write G mu nu as time is
just time so it's plus one so when
people say is time expanding no it's
just not that's a little bit unfair
because the whole point of
the metric is that it depends on the
coordinate system you use like even in
flat space if you use circular
coordinates right or you know polar
coordinates things like that the metric
can look different so the metric does
not instantly tell you the geometry of
space but it can be used to tell you the
geometry of space by massaging it in a
particular way but it's a indirect
relationship so that's why the curvature
tensor becomes important the curvature
tensor really does tell you the geometry
of space but you derive that from the
metric so the point of that was I can
choose weird coordinate systems in which
time changes in the metric from place to
place but I don't have to I can just
make it plus one whereas these plus ones
sorry
I like them these plus ones in the
Minkowski metric okay they will
necessarily have to change if the whole
thing we're just the Minkowski metric
then I would have flat space-time and
the answer is that we generally write it
as a squared as a function of time for G
xx and the same thing for G YY and for
gzz oops
shouldn't talk and write at the same
time and zeros elsewhere zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero this
is it this is I'm not fooling I'm not
had anything back right this is the
metric for a flat homogeneous and
isotropic expanding universe cosmology
what it's telling you is that time is
just time time clicks off and equal
intervals as the time coordinate T
changes but as the spatial coordinates
change or let's let's put it this way if
you have some object two objects at
fixed coordinates so here's an object at
just call it X call it X vector sub one
and here's another object at X vector
sub two okay and as time goes on there's
some distance between them D and as time
goes on their coordinates stay the same
so that by hypothesis let's say these
are two galaxies I'm choosing
to choose a coordinate system that stays
fixed along with the galaxies so us and
the galaxy that is ten billion light
years away or it fixed values of the
coordinates but the metric is changing
as time goes on so this is now well if
this is if this nice shouldn't right
that that's gonna get confusing but the
point is that the distance between them
is proportional to a as a function of
time okay
this is what it means for space to
expanse people will ask questions like
what is space expanding into right but
the whole point of differential geometry
alec allison riemann is we do
differential geometry intrinsically to
the manifold we're not embedded in
anything outside what it means that the
universe is expanding is the distance
between two objects at fixed coordinates
gets bigger because this thing called
the scale factor this is what we call it
which is part of the metric gets bigger
it grows over time if you were to plot a
as a function of time it goes up in fact
the universe is accelerating so now it
actually is going like it's more like
this
but it's going up its first a derivative
is positive that's what it means for
space to expand it means that the metric
is expanding in the spatial directions
so even if things are staying fixed in
coordinates the distance between them is
expanding there's nothing that it's
expanding into it's an intrinsic
property of space-time itself okay good
yeah I mean look by itself that is
pretty mind-bending right now you've
understood something about what it means
to say the universe is expanding now we
still have work to do okay that was nice
that was talking about paths and how to
measure them using the metric in
space-time what we really want is an
equation for the metric okay so in other
words there's two aspects to a theory
like general relativity one is how what
is the meaning of the metric and the
answer is it gives you distances
time's that's how you use the metric is
what you use to measure distances and
times to figure out what pads are stuff
like that geodesics all that stuff the
other question is what is the metric
what is the actual curvature of
space-time okay so you need an equation
for the metric and so that's what
Einstein figured out that he needed and
he set along how to do it and there's
sort of a conceptual set up but then
there's the actual work of finding the
equation so remember in general
relativity we have the metric which
defines the connection so we can still
do parallel transport right you can
still take a vector and parallel and
keep it as parallel to itself as it can
be as we move it along curves and that's
what the connection is and that tells us
what the curvature is okay and now that
I've given you a little bit of symbolism
I'm gonna fill that in and this is sort
of completely optional but the metric is
written G nu nu it's just a four by four
matrix in four dimensional space-time
the connection is written gamma capital
gamma Greek letter gamma with three
indices lambda mu nu call it okay this
is a function of the metric so you give
me the metric all over space-time I can
calculate the connection these are
coefficients if you want the connection
coefficients gamma lambda mu nu so this
is a set of four times four times four
equals 64 different numbers okay and
from that I can calculate the curvature
tensor are lambda Rho mu nu this is the
curvature tensor let me just write
tensor up there okay and we've already
mentioned what are Rome you knew is what
we what we said was that the curvature
tensor takes in three vectors V 1 V 2
and we said if you went around a little
parallelogram in this direction and then
you took another vector V 3 and it as it
goes around it will be rotated
by that much and the little deviation
which we labeled v4 was a way of
measuring how much curvature there is
you have to do that separately for all
the different ways you could rotate a
vector around a loop so for different
values of V 1 and V 2 and V 3 you get
different V fours and that's what our
does that's what the curvature tensor
does it tells you given V 1 V 2 V 3 what
is V 4 it is not therefore a coincidence
that when you look at the this symbolic
expression for the Riemann curvature
tensor there is 1 2 3 indices downstairs
and one upstairs this is basically what
it comes down to is these two indices
right here are where you put V 1 and V 2
here is where you put V 3 and here's
where you get out V 4 symbolically
speaking I just want to relate this way
of writing it to this way I told you
before so the way I talked to you before
was 3-month coverage of tensor was a map
from three vectors to one vector from v1
v2 v3 to v4 here I'm saying that our
lambda Rho mu nu is a collection of
components which is a well what it is is
a four by four matrix but instead of
each element being a number it is each
element is a four by four matrix so so
it looks like this horrible messy thing
where there you go 4 by 4 matrices
arranged into a four by four matrix some
of you might not even know what a matrix
is that's okay
all you need to know is sort of this
rectangular array of numbers one two
three four one two three four one two
three four one two three four
and every one of these every one of
these alone trees one two three four one
two three four one two three four one
two three four a lot of numbers making
up the Riemann curvature tensor that's
all I'm trying to say okay and the
reason why I have to remind you of this
is because we're looking for an equation
for the metric this is going to be how
we get the equation for the metric okay
so how do we do it so the the Riemann
curvature tensor is made
were made from the metric team you knew
and its derivatives how much is the
metric changing in the X direction the t
direction the Z direction etc so there's
some complicated formula for it I'm not
gonna tell you what that formula is you
can look it up I wrote a book remember
there's also free lecture notes online
if you prefer that method ok so this is
what we have to work with what we want
is an equation for the metric Latian for
the metric is what we want well we have
to work with is the Riemann curvature
tensor why because the Riemann curvature
tensor is the thing that tells you how
curved the metric is and doesn't tell
you anything else that's the important
information the metric itself suffers
from the flaw that if you change
coordinates its values change in ways
that do not reflect whether the metric
is curved or not whereas the curvature
tensor really cares about the curvature
so the curvature tensor is what you're
going to use so here are two ways of
getting an equation for the metric the
metric equation what you recall this is
the field equation for general
relativity because the metric tensor is
a field it exists at every point in
space-time right it has a value the
values not a number the values a little
4x4 matrix but there's a different value
at every point in space-time so it's a
metric tensor field so these are the
field equations for general relativity
that we want to get way one is to guess
and this was pioneered by mr. Einstein
because remember he was more of a
physicist than a mathematician so he had
this brilliant physical insight and he
just guessed the equation he did not
guess it immediately though because it's
still hard to get the right equation so
what do you have to work with remember
in Newtonian gravity remembered so
remember in Newtonian gravity you have
the force is G m1 m2 over R squared so
you have like the force due to gravity
on the left side on the right side you
have the mass right you have this idea
that it's the mass of the object that
gives rise to a gravitation
so Einstein knew that he had the
generalized this somehow and so he
already knew from special relativity
that mass and energy are closely related
and it turns out there's a way of
combining them in general relativity or
even in special relativity that makes
that unification of matter and energy
very manifest there's something called
the energy momentum tensor or sometimes
called the stress energy tensor I'm not
going to go into details about it but it
is called T mu nu so it is another four
by four matrix one two three four one
two three four one two three four one
two three four different entries in it
which tell you what is the energy
density the pressure the strain or
stress in different directions so if you
think like you have some fluid right you
have some continuum not just a point
particle you have some jello or some
rubber band or something like that you
can stretch it you can push it you can
twist it in different directions all
those things you can do to it carry
energy in some way carry pressure
carries stretching this tension and so
all of those are summarized in this four
by four matrix called the energy
momentum tensor so einstein's puzzle
when he was trying to guess the right
equation for general relativity was you
have the curvature of space-time which
is the characterized by the curvature
tensor R lambda Rho mu nu and you have
it's being you want to be sourced by
energy and momentum so somehow it's
related to team you knew and these muse
and news don't need to be the same
they're just indices telling you where
you are in the matrix but there's an
obvious problem this is a four by four
matrix this is a four by four matrix of
4 by 4 matrices it's not the right
amount of information to match up
somehow happily there's a mathematical
operation called contraction where
basically we can pick out pieces of a
tensor and combine them together giving
us a smaller tensor sensor with less
information but maybe the information we
need so you have the Riemann curvature
tensor lambda Rho
you knew ok Riemann tensor and what you
can do is define R Rho nu to be the sum
over lambda of our lambda Rho lambda nu
so in other words you can change this
you can force this index mu to be equal
to lambda and then you can sum over the
values here's mu right there
I set it equal to lambda and I sum over
all possible values namely zero one two
and three for the four dimensions of
space-time and this is a tensor that is
now not a matrix of matrices it's just a
four by four matrix it is called the
Ricci tensor it conveys some of the
information in the Riemann tensor but
not all of it and you can go further you
can actually contract the Ricci tensor
to get R and this is a little bit
trickier but I'm gonna write it as R
lambda lambda it's ashame these all use
the letter R but that is a convention in
relativity when you contract a tensor
you keep the big name of it the same you
just change the number of indices and
this is just called the curvature scalar
sometimes called the Ricci scalar but
this is called the curvature scalar okay
so the Riemann tensor is 128 different
entries four times four times four times
four the Ricci tensor is 16 entries four
times four and the curvature scales just
one number okay by the way there's
redundancies here like just like the
metric is symmetric
you always know that G X sorry G X y
equals g YX there's a lot of symmetries
and anti symmetries in this complicated
structure up here also but so we're not
gonna worry about counting the
independent components just counting the
total number of components so look
there's an obvious thing to guess if
Einstein's method for getting a field
equation for the metric is guessing
there's an obvious thing to guess so you
guess you look at this R Rho nu and say
maybe the Ricci tensor is just
proportional so there's some Kappa times
T Road
the indices had to match up on both
sides of an equation that's a rule okay
and this was a guess this is what he
said in fact I'll be a little bit more
conventional usually remember the the
indices are just made up there they're
just labels so I'm gonna call mu nu
because that's what they're usually
called in this context so Einstein
guessed this maybe the Ricci tensor
which is part of the Riemann tensor is
proportional to the energy momentum
tensor they both seem not as similar as
both symmetric to index tensors maybe
this makes sense
sadly energy is not conserved if this
equation is true and the Einstein again
he was not necessarily intuitive
mathematical genius but he was a physics
genius he figured this out quite quickly
so he knew this was not going to be the
right equation soon after he tried to
drive it so he did drive it he tried to
play with it a little bit it didn't
quite work what he eventually figured
out was he could say well can I modify
this so that energy is conserved and he
can with a better gas which in fact
comes out to be the correct gas that and
no reason why you would see why this is
the right gas but Einstein figured it
out arm you knew minus 1/2 are the
curvature scalar times the metric G mu
nu equals was proportional to so Kappa
some constant times T mu nu and this is
the correct thing I'm not gonna boss it
yet I'll box it soon
this combination of the Ricci tensor the
Ricci scalar the curricular in the
metric is called the Einstein tensor
because he invented it not bad for
someone who didn't love math and this is
the correct equation how do you know
it's the correct equation well among
other things you test it you do
experimental tests so you can do what is
called the Newtonian limit you can say
this equation for general relativity is
supposed to be true under all
circumstances but I can consider things
where G mu nu the metric is almost flat
and we can make that rigorous we can
specify what that means is very close to
the Minkowski metric for flat space-time
and the velocities of all objects that
you're looking at are much much
less than the speed of light which
equals one okay so the Newtonian limit
is both that gravity is weak compared to
what general relativity is prepared to
deal with but also that you're not
involved in special relativity either so
the speed of light is very very big
compared to what you look at it and what
you find is that Einstein's equation in
that limit says that it says exactly
what you want let me see how we wrote it
down that you would get a force equal to
G m1 m2 over R squared if kappa this
proportionality constant right there
equals 8 pi G therefore we say R mu nu
minus 1/2 R G mu nu equals 8 pi G
Newton's constant times T mu nu and that
is Einsteins field equations for general
relativity ok more details than you
wanted but again you know what I'm
trying to what I care about when I do
all this stuff introducing you know this
notation that you're never gonna use
again in your life etc if I want to give
you a feeling of flavor for what it's
like like it's easy to say oh yeah
space-time is curved and you guys that
rubber sheet with a ball in it but this
is what you actually do these are the
equations you're actually faced with if
you do general tivity for a living or
even you put it to good use in your
everyday life so I don't personally
really do much general tivity for living
but I use it everyday right I actually
use it in what I do for a living
cosmology and quantum gravity and stuff
like that it is a it's a subject that is
absolutely everywhere in astrophysics
cosmology fundamental physics things
like that
ok and so Einstein was very happy he
figured out he I think that he didn't
quite get there first this is what we
call Einstein's equation so now you know
e equals MC squared is not anywhere
close to Einsteins most important
equation this is Einsteins most
important equation this is the best
thing I Stine ever did right here he did
a lot of good things but this equation
figuring out I mean the idea that
space-time is curved that's good you or
I maybe could have come up with that but
then he figured out the equation
a little bit of work and he trained
himself how to do it from scratch he
didn't know differential geometry he
learned it and then did this with it so
not too shabby
but meanwhile you know he did he did you
know Einstein was not like Gauss you
know Gauss's rule was few but ripe he
wrote very very little Einstein wrote
papers like every day like he would just
write everything that popped into his
head and he would submit it to an Allah
to physique and Dera physique and so he
would he was definitely letting the
world know along the way what his
thoughts were going from the principle
of equivalence curved space-time
differential geometry to the equation
you know he was very open about what he
was doing so people pay attention to
that and there is another way to derive
Einstein equation the first play was
called guessing where is it yeah guess
the second way you could use the action
principle the principle of least action
right and this was put to work by David
Hilbert so Hilbert was one of the
world's best mathematicians unlike
Einstein who was the world's best
physicist Hilbert at the time was the
world's leading mathematician and so he
said you know he knew enough about
physics just like Einstein knew enough
about math to do differential geometry
Hilbert knew enough about physics to
know about the principle of least action
which says you have an action which is
an integral over time of a Lagrangian
and if it's a field theory you're
dealing with he knew that that was the
integral over D for X space end time
right T XY and Z of some lagrangian s'ti
okay this is how you define a theory and
the whole question is just what is curly
L what is the Lagrangian City
so unlike poor Einstein who had like all
of these tensors floating around with
all these different indices and you had
to guess like what goes where and so
forth
Hilbert knew that if he just jumped to
the action principle all he had to do is
get one function no indices at all right
and there's a lot more sorry there's a
lot fewer functions lying around
then there are tensors with whole bunch
of indices that's why figuring out new
theories by writing down their
lagrangian's is a much more sensible
thing to do than by guessing the
equations of motion like Einstein did in
fact there's kind of only one
well it's not only one but there is
certainly an obvious scalar function
floating around namely the curvature
scalar it's not the only one because we
could take the Riemann tensor and square
it okay in fact that's what you have to
do in other gauge theories if you do
electromagnetism or QCD or whatever you
take the curvature tensor and square it
to get the lagrangian but in gravity
there's this curvature scalar which
doesn't exist in the other gauge
theories because gravity is a little bit
different so this is a simpler thing you
could use and Hilbert figured that out
immediately Hilbert knew differential
geometry
he knew Gauss and Riemann and all that
so Hilbert's guess Hilbert says that the
lagrangian equals r and then plus some
lagrangian for everything else which
we'll call matter right so the Gwangi is
just our x matter and there's some
coefficient out here and it's gonna work
out to be 1 over 16 pi g let me write
that bigger for you the correct
coefficient to get everything right in
general relativity is 16 pi G is the
hole grown gene and so Hilbert guessed
this immediately like overnight
maybe not overnight but very quickly he
figured out once einstein had explained
you know what he was looking for and
what the tools were what the rules of
the game were he guessed this and this
goes right to you you get the least
action you do the calculus of variations
you find out what is the path of least
action what is the equation that
describes it and it is exactly
Einstein's equation and so this trouble
that Einstein had with energy not being
conserved is immediately automatically
solved by the action principle that's
the nice thing about the Lagrangian of
the principle of least action all the
symmetries all that stuff are
automatically taken care of because
there's not a lot of freedom in guessing
a scalar function from which you can
derive the equations of motion so we
actually call even though this equation
is the Einstein equation ok this action
s equals D for X oops integral d for X
I'm cheating a little bit because the D
for X needs to be modified in curved
space-time but you don't need to
about that one over 16 PI G or plus
whatever it is for matter this is called
the Einstein Hilbert action and there's
controversy over whether Hilbert or
Einstein actually got there first with
the equation I think that the answer is
it at Einstein gets all the credit and
deserves all the credit
um certainly Hilbert was working with
Einsteins ideas from the start when he
did it but I think even getting the
equation Einstein got it first even
though Hilbert might have said it out
loud first okay but I do want to
emphasize it because it fits in with our
previous discussion of field theories
and quantum field theories working from
the action principle finding Lagrangian
you can do that too in general
relativity and it gets you it gets you
there very quickly okay I know we're
going long but this is so good I gotta
keep going I gotta keep telling you some
of the consequences here this is general
relativity all in one video ok so I
almost had lecture almost in one video
we're getting all of general ativy so
it's very important so think about some
consequences of general relativity
remember we told you the consequences in
terms of particles moving on geodesics
etc now we have the Einstein equation
for the metric we can figure out what
the consequences of that are now
Einstein by the way he derived this he
never thought it would be easy to solve
this equation or even possible to solve
it because this is a short compact
equation but it could it hides a lot of
complication right because this are both
of these ARS are contractions of the
Riemann curvature tensor dream on
curvature tensor is a function of the
connection coefficients those gammas and
those gammas are functions of the metric
team you knew and its derivatives and
the derivatives are everywhere and so if
you wrote this out in you could write
out this whole equation just in terms of
the metric and it would fill up a whole
page of text ok it's incredibly
complicated it's not like Newton's
little equation so when it comes to
physics questions physics theories
beauty is in the eye of the beholder you
know from the point of view of when you
understand a differential geometry this
is a very beautiful equation a very
beautiful theory but if you just wrote
it
out as a field equation for the metric
people think he would gone mad it looks
completely crazy and very difficult to
solve so Einstein himself was
pessimistic about ever solving it and so
he was a bit surprised when in 1917
Schwarz yield Karl Schwarzschild see if
I can spell his name correctly came up
with an exact solution to general
relativity to this equation in a very
simple context so Schwartz yield said
let's look at spiracle e symmetric
solutions so basically which fortune was
after was the metric of the
gravitational field of the Sun for
example this is supposed to be gravity
we're talking about so you have the Sun
at the center he's gonna idealize it as
a point mass so forget about the size of
the Sun or the interior just look at
outside the Sun okay just like Newton
doesn't need to worry about the force
due to gravity inside the earth or the
Sun he could ask you can say that
outside is an inverse square law so he
looks at spherical symmetry and because
he's outside he looks at the vacuum in
other words he looks at places where the
energy momentum tensor is zero so inside
the Sun it's not zero but we're gonna
remove that we're not gonna look at that
so we have the Sun here here's the Sun
but we're gonna say let's just take out
that sphere and forget it and ask what
is the metric out here okay as a
function of let's say R the distance
from the center so we're gonna use
radial coordinates polar coordinates and
he finds an exact solution and even more
impressive he was a soldier in the
German army and he was at the front this
is like literally he did this on the
basis of reading Einstein's papers at a
time when by the way Einstein didn't
really have it right and so I'm still
groping toward the final answer so
Schwartz he was handicapped by that but
like he was literally fighting on the
front and then to pass the time he
learned general relativity and then
solved the equations and he was then
killed soon thereafter he didn't die
like a gunshot it was like pneumonia but
he he died very young but he managed to
do that and so his name is never gonna
go away
historically so in polar coordinates
what does that mean that means that you
have and this is just in space okay so
this is X Y Z so this is not space time
time is just time here but instead of
using XYZ coordinates
let's use our and then if you drop down
this point to the XY plane this angle
here is Phi and this angle here is Theta
okay so you have R theta and Phi
coordinates this may or may not be
familiar to you but don't worry about it
if it's not the point is that I'm gonna
compare what the flat space-time metric
is in polar coordinates to what Swart
Shields metric is you can see how it
actually changes so Jean you knew the
metric which I said is minus one plus
one plus one plus one in rectangular
coordinates Cartesian coordinates in
space-time Minkowski coordinates in
polar coordinates it's minus one nothing
happens to time plus one in the dr
squared direction R squared in the D
theta squared direction and R squared
sine squared theta in the D Phi squared
direction okay so in other words the
distance in space-time is minus DT
squared plus D R squared plus R squared
D theta squared plus R squared sine
squared theta D Phi squared this is flat
space-time this is just flat space-time
in a weird coordinate system okay not
that weird but a little bit different
than what we had before so short Shield
does his work and I'm not gonna
reproduce all his work and we're just
gonna write to the answer so the
Schwarzschild metric G mu nu is minus
the quantity 1 minus 2 G M over R by the
way I said C equals 1 right the speed of
light is equal to 1 everywhere here so
this is G's Newton's constant of gravity
M is the mass of the Sun or whatever
other object it is you're looking at and
R is the distance between the center of
the coordinates and wherever you are
so you notice as R goes to infinity
to GM over R goes to zero and this goes
to -1 so far far away from the Sun this
quantity right here goes to -1 so far
away from the Sun space-time looks flat
that makes sense
the next thing I need to write it I need
to sort of squeeze down here maybe I can
move myself over a little bit mm-hmm get
myself a little bit more room here I'm
gonna be able to compare it to the flat
space-time version the RR component the
thing that multiplies dr squared is plus
1 minus 2 GM over R to the minus 1 power
ok
but again as R goes to infinity to GM
over R goes to 0 so this just goes to
plus 1 which is what we want it to do
and then these components aren't even
change it's just R squared and R squared
sine squared theta I'll leave it to you
to take this metric calculate its
Riemann curvature tensor calculate the
Ricci tensor and the Ricci scalar and
show that it obeys Einstein's equation
and thank you but it does so Einstein
was very impressed that shorty was able
to do that that's very good and when you
can do with that that is the metric
around an object in outside the object
not in the interior but outside so this
is the equivalent of the Newtonian
gravitational field around an object
this is the curved space-time metric DT
squared and dr squared have components
that vary with are unlike they do in
just flattened space-time so we can put
this to work and you know again Einstein
didn't know this
deine stein didn't have this metric when
he first met in general relativity so he
did things like the precession of
mercury okay if you look up a book like
mine on general relativity you will see
the precession of mercury derived so
here's the Sun again and then here's
mercury a little planet going around the
Sun and goes in an ellipse if you were
Newton's laws but according to general
relativity you get almost Newton's law
but that's in the weak field gravity
regime mercury is close enough to the
Sun the gravity is pretty weak but it's
a little bit not weak okay there's a
deviation from Newtonian gravity and
what you get is that over time this
ellipse moves that's called the
precession of mercury and I was to
finish the sentence if you look up in a
book like mine you derive the precession
of mercury from the short Shield metric
but originally Einstein derived it
without knowing the short ship metric he
just used perturbation theory kind of
like the general relativity equivalent
Fineman diagrams to figure out what the
precession should be he got the right
answer this is you know I I can't even
imagine what it would have been like to
be Einstein and get the right answer for
the precession of mercury was already
known physicists already knew that
mercury was moving in a way that didn't
seem to fit in didn't tony and
prediction they figured that it was
probably some hidden planet like it had
previously worked that the outer planets
right like saturn and uranus didn't move
in exactly the right way and they said
well if there's another planet out there
perturbing it maybe that would explain
it and they discovered neptune so they
played the same game for mercury they
imagined there was a hidden planet near
the Sun they called it Vulcan it was
discovered several times but never
correctly people thought they saw it and
they were not right and Einstein figured
out that it wasn't a hidden planet at
all it was actually a new theory of
gravity there is a lesson there for
people who are thinking about dark
matter right dark matter and dark energy
are gravitational effects that are
purportedly due to things we don't see
it's very much like the history of
looking for planets in the solar system
the successful discovery of Neptune was
an example of where you thought that
your theory of gravity did not fit so
you posited a new source and then you
found it the unsuccessful hypothesis of
Vulcan is an example where you thought
your theory of gravity didn't fit so you
have to change your theory of gravity
okay I think and we'll talk later but I
think that in the case of dark matter
and dark energy we've done that thought
experiment and we know that there really
is some new stuff there not a new theory
of gravity but we're not 100% sure so
it's good to keep an open mind about
those things okay so this fit perfectly
and you know when I
I figured it out it's a very precise
number it's not like a qualitative
feature there's an exact number that was
known for how much mercury was
discrepant by an Einstein's new theory
predicted it perfectly and he must been
very very happy when that happened that
doesn't happen very often in the
lifetime of a theoretical physicist but
there it did another thing that you can
do is the bending of light so this is an
example of how general relativity is not
just a cool fun theory but it's a
unification it brings together not just
space and time but it sort of explains
what gravity is as the curvature of
space-time in a way that is just more
sensible than the Newtonian way of
thinking about it so the procession of
light says if you have a star like the
Sun for example and a little light beam
goes by it it will be bent okay by the
gravitational field and you can
calculate exactly by how much and you
get the right answer and then Arthur
Eddington did an eclipse expedition he
claimed to measure the right answer he
may have fudged his data or not it's not
clear to me anyway but now we've done it
very very accurately we know that
Einstein again was exactly right the
reason why this is impressive is not
because here I mean here the number is
sort of what you would guess like it's
not as precise as the mercury thing oops
mercury should be spelled correctly
there you go
what's what's impressive is that in
Newtonian gravity it's not even clear
what you mean like how you would do this
cuz for Newton F equals MA right
that's the whole motivating equation for
Newtonian mechanics and but for light M
equals zero there's it's a massless
particle so maybe it's not accelerated
at all by gravity right or maybe you say
F equals G mm over R squared and you
cancel the ends and so the M doesn't
matter even when it's zero but you don't
know is the point is just ambiguous and
general relativity has no such ambiguity
it gives you the answer and the answer
is right and so that's very impressive
okay next consequence we're gonna zoom
through some consequences of general
relativity another one is the
gravitational redshift
this is another one that Einstein came
up with right away in fact actually it's
an interesting history because the
gravitational redshift is in some sense
consequence not of general relativity
full-blown but immediately of the
equivalence principle you can do a
little thought experiment we're not
gonna do it right here but sorry let me
tell you what the redshift is basically
here's the earth or whatever and you
have a tower and on top of the tower you
build an observation deck and then you
send a light ray from down here and it
has some wavelength lambda 0 and it's
observed up here with some wavelength
lambda 1 and the prediction of general
relativity is the lambda 1 is greater
than lambda 0 the light has been a
redshift that has it climbed out of the
gravitational potential well and you can
get this just from the principle of
equivalence by saying imagine that the
light is not climbing out of some
gravitational potential well but is
being sent between two rocket ships that
are accelerating right and as the rocket
ships accelerate of course the velocity
of the rocket ship increases so there's
a Doppler effect the straightforward
Doppler effect says that the light that
gets to the rocket ship ahead of it
should be red shifted okay so you get
this answer and you get it
quantitatively correct even without
knowing the Einstein field equations it
comes right from the principle of
equivalence it took a while natural
1960s that this was actually measured
but again Einstein was right once again
another important consequence I'm gonna
say is cosmology because again much like
the deflection of light where you could
try to do a newtonian version and
compared to general relativity but the
Newtonian thing is just ill-defined it's
just not clear what is going on same
thing is true in cosmology and so what I
mean in this case by cosmology is just
the simplest thing you can imagine where
you you you imagine that this is space
ok space you fill it with matter
uniformly this is what you're going to
decide to do I'm just going to fill
space with matter uniformly so there's
some constant energy density Rho all
throughout space dust or stars sprinkled
uniformly throughout space and you ask
what happens ok so from the atonium
point of view you might say well what
happens if I focus on one
particle here and one particle here they
both pull on each other right so they
should come closer together that make
sense gravity pulls on everything so
that's one answer you can get but
there's another answer you can get from
the laplacian point of view you say
there's a potential field and then the
force due to gravity is the derivative
of fine in the spatial direction but
here because the energy density is
constant everywhere the potential field
should also be constant and therefore
there is no derivative the derivatives
are zero the potential is constant
everywhere so this is saying that well
yeah this this point is being pulled by
that one but it's also being pulled by
one on the other side and therefore
nothing happens so there's in one way of
thinking about the problem all the
particles come together in Newtonian
gravity and another way of thinking
about it everything just sits there
because all the forces exactly cancel
and there's no obvious way of answering
that question
you can argue into it whatever answer
you want but you can all argue the
opposite way also nothing like that is
true in general relativity in general
relativity there's an unambiguous answer
and there is this scale factor as a
function of time and then we get an
equation the Hubble constant equals 8 pi
G over 3 Rho where the Hubble constant H
is the expansion rate of the universe
technically H equals 1 over a times the
derivative a respect to time where a is
that scale factor ok so there's an
unambiguous equation saying it you
sprinkle energy density evenly
throughout the universe that's Rho then
there will be an expansion rate or a
contraction rate because H could be
negative h squared and this is what led
Einstein he was able to do this in his
head and he said oh ok so the universe
must need to be expanding or contracting
and then this is where I think it's a
bit of a bad rap because there's a story
that floats around that says that
Einstein derived that in general
relativity if you had a uniform
distribution of stuff spatially the be
expanding or contracting and he had some
philosophical
predisposition to think that the
universe was static so he got upset by
this and he invented the cosmological
constant which you can add to this plus
lamda basically there might be some
factors I think it's land over 3 and if
lambda is no it's minus lambda over 3
how do I know that because the point is
that a positive lambda can overcome can
compensate for the energy density
because lambda pushes the universe apart
so this is the cosmological constant and
so Einstein said well I can change my
equations by adding a cosmological
constant and that wasn't such a bad
thing to do like the cows Marshall
constant as we would now say represents
the energy density empty space so it
should be there anyway in some sense but
the point is Einstein did not have some
philosophical conviction that space was
not expanding in fact when he predicted
that space should either be expanding or
contracting there was a moment when he
was kind of excited like maybe that's
true right and he asked his astronomer
friends and we're talking now 19:17 or
there abouts okay and as astronomer
friends in 1917 it like space isn't
expanding no because all they knew about
was that's where the stars in the Milky
Way and on average the stars in the
Milky Way are not moving away from us or
toward us there's some individual
motions but they average out to out zero
and so these drummer friends told him
space is static so what he did was the
correct scientific thing to do in the
face of data that did not fit his theory
he came up with a better theory right
now later ten years later in 1927 Hubble
and his friends show the universe is
expanding the nine steinfeldt that he'd
missed his chance like if he had ignored
his observational astronomer friends and
just said space must either be expanding
or contracting he would have had another
wonderful prediction but he didn't
that's okay I don't blame him you know
he didn't know that we were only looking
at stuff in the galaxy okay two more
quick consequences of Einstein's
equation here is what we're gonna do
gravitational time dilation we did time
dilation for special relativity that is
to say if you zip out near the speed of
light and zip back you're moving on a
non geodesic path you need to accelerate
out and back
okay so you will general experience less
time than you would if you stayed home
so that's where you get the twin paradox
from in special relativity but now we
get it
even if you're stationary you can get
time dilation and that's because of the
Schwarzschild metric let's look back up
here okay let's see if I can do this
always kind of an adventure cutting and
pasting in this program copy so we have
the Schwarzschild metric there it is it
worked with some extra pieces and what
we notice is that this first term this
term up here what is that that is the
part of the space-time metric that is
multiplying DT squared the change in the
time coordinate okay so what that means
is that constant R so let's imagine that
you're on the surface of a planet or
you're orbiting a planet okay you so you
can move in theta and Phi but you're at
a constant distance from the center of
the planet then look what this means is
that the time that you feel the change
in time experienced is equal to well
let's say I'll write it this way change
in time experience squared that's the DS
squared that we had before equals 1
minus 2 GM over R times Delta T the
coordinate so this is the time
coordinate remember in relativity
coordinates are different than what you
experienced that's the whole point of
having the metric and being able to
transform back and forth sorry
everything here is squared but I'm gonna
remove the squares let's get rid of the
squared so we can just see what is going
on directly and the minus sign
disappeared because because how to say
this D s squared this
ace time interval is G mu nu DX mu DX nu
but the proper time the actual time
elapsed follows D tau squared equals
minus D s squared so that I mean this is
not supposed to be too surprising the
amount of time you experience is a real
number not at an imaginary number so if
you get that you know delta T squared is
minus something you better there better
be a minus sign in there that fixes it
this is where it is this is where that
minus sign is so that minus sign goes
away
and you get this equation oh sorry I
didn't finish it
this part isn't squared this is the
square root of this there we go oh okay
this is the real equation so even if you
didn't follow all that very very quick
running out of time in my life
explanation this is the final answer
okay this is the relationship between
the amount of time you experience the
amount of time you would actually
measure on your clock and the time
coordinate at constant R in the short
sealed metric and if you were to plot
this to make a little bit more vivid
what do we have here as a function of R
this is the square root of 1 minus 2 GM
over R so there's obviously something
special going on at R equals 2 GM let's
not get into that right now but at R
equal to GM this is 1 minus 1 so this is
0 and then as you go to R equals
infinity get larger and larger R to GM
over R becomes smaller and smaller this
becomes more and more close to the
square root of 1 which is 1 so if we put
one right here the curve that we have it
looks like this
so you asymptote to 1 okay so what this
is saying is if you're sitting let's say
you're sitting here at 3 GM R equals 3
GM okay then this coefficient is a
smaller number than it is out here at 8
GM or whatever okay so as you get closer
and closer to the gravitating object for
a given change in T the time coordinate
there is less and less change in your
time experience do you experience less
and
time when you're down there in a
gravitational field this is that is a
correct way of saying it it'd be even
more correct to compare two trajectories
that start at the same point in
space-time and ended at the same point
but the slightly misleading way that
this is sometimes translated as saying
clocks run more slowly in a
gravitational field clocks run at one
second per second no matter where they
are but if you compare clocks at
different distances from the
gravitational field they will appear to
run at different rates if you can
compare them in some sensible way this
is where that comes from now you know it
now you know the formula for it it comes
from the Schwarzschild metric it comes
from the fact that in the metric
describing the curvature around a
spherically symmetric object the
coefficient of time depends on where you
are in space it depends on how close you
are to the gravitating object and
therefore the rate at which time flows
from the point of view of someone very
far away depends on how close you are to
the gravitational field that's a pretty
cool thing finally file conclude final
consequence is that there are these
things called black holes okay oops I
thought one more consequence just now at
Elte at the end why are there black
holes well look we we saw here there's
clearly in the short field metric
something going on at R equals 2 GM
right at R equals 2 GM this quantity
goes to zero so it looks like time isn't
flowing that's weird but worse this
quantity goes to infinity because it's
zero to the minus 1 power that's
definitely weird it turns out this is
just because all of these coordinates
are bad at R equals 2 GM R equals 2 GM
is not something where it's a true
singularity nothing is really blowing up
or an infinite coordinates are tough and
Einstein and struggle with this himself
for a long time like coordinates a bad
choice of coordinates can lead you to
think terrible things are happening in
general tivity when really they're not
okay so the Schwarzschild metric in
these coordinates just doesn't work at R
equals 2 GM there's really nothing
special there's no nothing singular
about it so there it does exist it is an
interesting place R equals 2 GM is
called the Schwarzschild
and I was gonna do that eventually and
typically for something like the Sun or
the earth the size of the object is way
bigger than the Schwarzschild radius so
the short shield metric only works
outside the object so what happens at
article 2 GM is completely irrelevant
for the Sun or the earth because you're
always inside the object at R equals 2
GM but there are things called black
holes where you take the whole mass of
the Sun and shrink it within its short
shield radius and then this is where the
event horizon is of the black hole and
we can now finally this is that if you
if you follow me this long if you're
still watching you deserve the following
pay off you deserve the following reward
this is like one of those things when
you teach general relativity the class
is you get to this in like week eight or
something like that and it is you know
it makes the students so happy when we
get to this fact what's going on and R
equals to G M well we can plot it in a
spacetime diagram okay so imagine this
is X Y T so space-time diagram so and
here is R equals to G M Schwarzschild
radius so R is the radial coordinate
here R and let's just draw this sort of
Schwarzschild radius at all times good
like that what's happening is if you
look at the form of the short shield
metric as you go to large R everything
just looks like flat Minkowski
space-time so we can actually
characterize that by drawing the light
cones we just draw it down here a little
bit so if you start from a point you
just draw the light beams going out of
45 degrees and a physical trajectory has
to stay inside the light cone it can't
move faster than the speed of light but
if you follow if you did this at home I
do encourage you to do it's kind of fun
draw curves in the R T plane
so forget about theta and Phi who cares
about those but draw curves in the RT
plane and draw them so that D s squared
equals zero that's what the light cone
is the light cone is d s squared equals
zero speed of light okay
as you go closer to the black hole to
the Schwarzschild radius what happens is
the light cones tilt so what happens is
the light cones begin to tilt toward the
black hole so you can it's easier if you
like to travel in the direction of the
black hole and harder to move away from
it you still can but it becomes harder
and the event horizon is exactly R
equals 2 GM is exactly where the light
cones start looking like this they're
tilted so much that now every physically
allowed trajectory goes to smaller and
smaller values of R okay going more
slowly than the speed of light means
going towards smaller values of R that's
what's happening inside the event
horizon not outside and that continues
all the way in once you're inside the
black hole yeah light cones look like
this and you're just forced to go all
the way to are I do this yeah I can do
this because I can rotate my pad to R
equals zero that is called R equals zero
is the singularity and once you are
inside the black hole and your light
cones are tilting like that there's
nothing you can do other than be driven
all the way to R equals zero okay so
that's fact number one that is important
about black holes the first fact is
space-time is so curved that simply the
requirement that you have to move slower
than the speed of light becomes the
requirement that you have to stay that
you have to go to decreasing values of R
all the way to our equals zero the
second fact is that that location R
equals zero is not a point in space okay
it is a moment in time we think about
decreasing R as moving toward the center
right but that's just because we are
used to coordinates in which R equals
zero is the center the if you if you go
back to the Schwarzschild metric when R
is less than 2 GM this number here in
front of DT squared is positive even
though there's a minus sign out front if
R is less than
this is one - a number bigger than one
so this is a negative number inside the
parentheses times a times a negative
number is a positive number so this is a
positive number in front of DT squared
and this number is negative because R is
greater than two GM so this is bigger
than one so one minus a negative number
is a negative number to the -1 power is
still a negative number so inside the
event horizon R becomes what we call the
time like coordinate and the T becomes
the space like a coordinate so R equals
zero is not a point at the center of the
black hole it is a moment in the future
the reason why once you're inside the
black hole you cannot help but hit the
singularity is because you cannot help
but age forward in time it's a bad
coordinate choice like I said to use R
and T but if you want to do that you can
just keep in mind that R goes to zero is
like going into the future you can no
more avoid hitting the singularity then
you could avoid hitting tomorrow and
that's why black holes are cool and
that's why the event horizon is such a
cool thing they memorize it in the
singularity in fact there's a better way
very very quickly there's a better way
better coordinate system called Kruskal
coordinates to draw the black hole in
which call it capital R and capital T
and the event horizon looks like this
this is R equals little articles to GM
looks like a light cone which is true
because it is a light cone because
that's that's the light cone is on the
event horizon the event rise in R equals
constant R equals to GM but it's a null
trajectory and the singularity is this
it's a moment in the future this is R
equals zero so you travel in and you're
gonna hit the future that's what it is
the singularity is a moment in your
future okay that's what if that's what
black holes are all about Einstein had
no idea about any of this because it
wasn't figured out I know more about
general relativity even Einstein did not
because I'm anywhere near as smart as
Einstein but because we have learned a
lot about general relativity in the
years since and that's exciting
the last consequence is gravitational
waves I'm not gonna write anything down
but I do want to let you know
we discovered gravitational waves just a
few years ago 2016 at Lego but there
were another prediction of general
relativity right from the start another
prediction that was hard to make sure
whether it was real because of
coordinate issues we didn't know whether
it was just the coordinates that were
varying or truly the curvature of
space-time eventually we figured it out
but the point is the gravitational waves
take us all the way back to here
remember Newtonian gravity I said we
started this video by saying you could
to send information faster than the
speed of light by moving something very
quickly in its gravitational field would
change instantly throughout the universe
in general relativity that's not true in
general relativity the story is exactly
equivalent to the story we told about
electromagnetic radiation
electromagnetic waves you take an
electron and move it up and down the
electric field vibrates and those
vibrations spread out at the speed of
light in general relativity exactly the
same thing is true nothing - enough to
draw the picture but if you take let's
say two objects two black holes or two
stars and let the more but each other so
they're moving their gravitational field
changes as a function of time but it
doesn't change instantaneously
throughout the universe it ripples out
at the speed of light so Einstein's
equation made that prediction and this
is why Einstein equation is so awesome
this is this is the great thing about
really powerful theories of physics is
that they predict more than you start
with like Einstein was just trying to
satisfy the principle of equivalence
right he was just trying to say like
let's do some math that is compatible
with the idea that in small regions of
space-time physics looks like special
relativity and energy momentum is
conserved and all that stuff all the
things that we care about here's the
unique equation I come up with and out
of that you predict the expansion of the
universe and black holes and
gravitational waves and everything and
it's still true like this is a 19-15
equation no experiment we've done more
than a hundred years later has shown any
deviation from this equation at all ah
there's a an industry that says well
maybe we should modify Einstein's
equation even in cosmology yeah I guess
this is the last thing that's a good
ending point we know of course we should
modify Einstein's equation it's a
classical equation there's no quantum
mechanics in there at all right
so Einstein's equation as good as it is
even though it's it's passed all the
experimental tests we've done is
probably not almost certainly not the
final answer of how gravity works in
nature because it's not quantum
mechanical at all however we can think
of general relativity as an effective
field theory when we talk about
effective field theories we said that
you could put a cutoff at short
distances and say that you don't know
what physics is going on that distance
is smaller than that
okay but you do know what physics is
going on a distance is larger than that
and that is generally the way you would
expect field theories to work in the
real world so even though we don't
expect on a science equation to be
absolutely understand correct in the
world we do expect that it should be
correct above a distance is longer than
we've tested it and we've tested at
distances about that big about a tenth
of a millimeter to be honest okay so
everywhere above the tenth to the
millimeter Einstein's equation seems to
work and from a theoretical perspective
from our theoretical bias from our
priors and a Bayesian sense there's no
reason to think that it should be
modified or changed in any way you're
allowed to try I have tried others try
people still try to modify Einstein's
equations that'll be very surprising it
would not be surprising to see
variations of Einstein's equations at
short distances but seeing them in long
distances even though Einstein's
equation works really really well here
in the solar system is exactly the
opposite of what we would expect and
indeed we've seen zero evidence for it
so far so my guess is as far as the
larger universe is concerned this
equation of Professor Einsteins is the
correct equation for gravity and now you
know what it is